crunch time for the White House and
House Republicans to hammer out a deal
to raise the debt ceiling and avert a
potentially disastrous government
default on Friday treasury secretary
Janet Yellen extended the deadline to
June 5th as lawmakers headed home for
the Memorial Day holiday weekend this
gives negotiators a few more days to
come to an agreement President Biden
remains optimistic they are very close
to reaching a deal despite being divided
on sticking points Christina raffini has
more from the White House and joins us
now Christina good morning
good morning Dana well optimism is good
but lawmakers worked late into last
night and still went home without a
final deal
with regard to the debt limit things are
looking good and very optimistic on his
way to Camp David for the holiday
weekend President Biden sounded upbeat
and hopeful we'll know by tonight
whether we are going to be able to have
a deal but after a full day of meetings
and I want to be able to solve this
problem Republican negotiators last
night sounded less sure some Catholic
everybody
away
[Music]
Beaker McCarthy left the capital without
a deal and without speaking to reporters
Friday afternoon treasury secretary
Janet Yellen gave the fraught team
project a bit of an extension
informing Congress that the U.S can make
it four extra days to June 5th before
reaching its borrowing limit
[Music]
you know really identified where the
business differences are but that
doesn't mean the urgency has dissipated
now we know
um
CBS News has learned the potential deal
will likely raise the debt limit for
about two years cap federal spending for
two years excluding defense and veterans
benefits and increase all discretionary
spending including defense by one
percent in 2025. one remaining sticking
point work requirements for social
welfare benefits including nutritional
Assistance programs are you willing to
drop that work requirements and they
just hell no not a chance in a statement
Friday evening the White House accused
Republicans of trying to take food out
of the mouths of hungry Americans and
said Democrats would stand against quote
this cruel and senseless trade-off
now even in law as lawmakers focus on
trying to cut spending America's biggest
bills are off the table including
Medicare Social Security Medicare
spending sorry military spending and
Veterans Affairs now remember Michelle
even if they do cut a deal the house by
its own rules still needs about 72 hours
to review it
let's hope the fourth day is a charm
Christina perfini thank you